hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast primary cell systems
offerings and applications from basic
biology and tissue modeling to compound
screening presented by dr. David hunter
and dr. Rhonda Newman
I'm Christina Jewell of lab rats and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's webinar is brought to you by lab
groups and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsors please visit thermo Fisher comm
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into that ask a
question box on the left side of your
screen and click the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click support tab sound at
the top right of the presentation window
or click on the answer question box and
report your problems we have two
presenters for you today dr. David
Thomas connector and dr. Rhonda Newman
for detailed biographies on our speakers
please click on the speaker biographies
tab at the top of your screen so without
further ado dr. contenders dr. Newman
you may now begin your presentation
great thanks for the introduction
Christy and we'll just get rolling so
and again thank you all for you know for
dialing in or clicking in it's really
our pleasure to share with you our
primary cell portfolio some key key
applications and yeah so I with that I'm
on the second slide so yeah this just
outlines an overview of our talk so so
first really is you know what is the
portfolio you know what do we offer and
then a highlight of some key
applications that we thought would be
interesting in terms of different ways
to use primary cells to study various
aspects of biology and different
signaling pathways utilizing various
technologies from the thermo Fisher
Scientific broad portfolio of technology
and instrumentation and then end up with
with Rhonda speaking specifically on
using primary cells for creating organic
typic skin models and some of the
important applications those are used
for
so so this slide three shows an overview
of the cell types that we offer and I
should say these are they expand various
tissue types developmental stages
principally their human origin although
we do have a few non-human cell types
principally these are going to be
provided as cryopreserved self
excuse me although we we have a few
examples are few offerings of
proliferating cells and and certainly
flexibility to provide live cell
cultures if that's needed on a custom
basis
you
slide 4 so you know really the key to
being able to develop and offer a broad
portfolio of primary cells is access to
tissue high-quality tissue is really
critical this slide highlights not
meaning to gross you guys out but you
know where the cells are derived from so
this is a typically comes from two major
sources which are indicated in the
second bullet on the right so we work
closely with tissue procurement networks
and organ donation groups as well as
local clinics or medical centers and and
really there's two for tissue that would
be you know potentially trans
transplantable you know the use and
humans for transplant for for
life-saving or extending applications is
always a you know primary use of those
tissues and organs but but often or at
least with some regularity
we can't want can't align donors
appropriate donors with those tissues so
it to prevent them from you know going
to waste and being able to leverage
these you know very valuable tissues and
gifts from from individuals we along
with other providers are lined up to
accept these within a reasonable window
and then isolate various primary cell
types from them on the other other side
of things there are some tissues that
are just discarded as part of normal
medical practices the upper right image
shows a umbilical vein so these are
where we isolate two backs from so it's
a you know typically not saved discarded
as part of the sort of birthing process
does the lower left image shows actually
a fairly good-sized chunk of skin that
was removed from an elective of the
cosmetic surgery procedure so again
various sources that we get these from
we have extent
that works on how to source ages you
know donor different donor profiles this
is all highly regulated space you know
we're compliant with with federal and
European guidelines for you know
compliance with confidentiality with
HIPPA with procurement and use standards
we can also provide some some
institutions or uses it's important to
have traceability back to donor consent
we can provide donor consent forms for
each you know source tissue as needed so
and you know that's far I'll kind of you
know if different different types of
cells sort of where we get them from
from a tissue standpoint but but really
to get the most value out of the cells
it's really a self system that that's
required these again are specialized
human cells and as such they typically
require specialized or purpose-designed
culture conditions and this is something
we we especially spend a lot of time to
develop and put together so the slide
really just highlights that concept is
that now we have not only the cells that
I showed but but basal media that's
designed for those cells or cell types
supplements that are again are
purpose-built for the maintenance of
sort of maintaining the physiological
characteristics of the tissues from
which the cells were derived and other
reagents for you know general culture
expansion current preservation so it's
really we look at it holistically and
really try to provide these types of
complete solutions
existence provides maybe a little bit
more of a specific example of what you
know a system could look like and also I
think highlights a couple other aspects
so often we have a range of options in
terms of you know if you want for
example a carrot Innosight you know a
skin epithelial barrier so we can you
know we have adult Mia natal or pooled
even within these if there's some
specific donor traits we can you know
sort of select for those or you can look
for those so there's sort of a range of
cells in this case with the
keratinocytes and the basal medium we
have a range of basal media and
supplement combinations and these can be
you know really from our most robust and
I guess robust would be you know that
would maximize the growth conditions
this typically means it has the highest
protein content and likely contains
undefined products
excuse me um such as a serum or in the
case of the keratinocyte supplements the
animal products here I'm referring to
are is both on pituitary extract so
their serum free but have a pituitary
gland Euler extract as part of it
however if you know you would want to
have more defined conditions if that's
important for particular you know assay
endpoints or applications where you you
know you really want to have a more
defined culture condition again we offer
that with with two different supplements
in this case for examples our EDG s
supplement or the s7 which are neither
of which contain the bovine pituitary
extract but but are either defined or
completely animal origin free and as you
is it's kind of a general rule of thumb
as as you get to more defined culture
conditions there generally have lower
protein content and also the need for
extra cellular matrix support typically
goes hand-in-hand with using defined
conditions particularly for the primary
cells so so in this case we're I'm
highlighting the use of coding matrix
this is actually recombinant human
collagen type ones solution that's
really required for the you know
effective culture in the defined
conditions so this is you know again how
we've worked all of these you know sort
of options out in advance I won't go
into you know sort of great detail with
the other cell types and media options
but but you can go to our you know
primary cells web page and see see that
okay so yeah I touched on matrices for
the keratinocytes they you know
typically you know in the dermal
keratinocytes like collagen that's the
sort of their natural environment or at
least for bio march they attach well to
collagen we offer a range of other
matrices that are shown here that are
either recumbent flavors depending on
your particular requirements for for 2d
culture and then we have two matrices
listed below the alginate ryx and gel
tracks these can be used for both 2d or
3d culture and I'll give you an example
of some some 3d culture on the next
slide
yeah so and this these are I guess I
take maybe more classic applications of
3d culture using gel tracks and primary
cells so the upper set of images are an
angiogenesis a tube formation assay so
we actually sell a can't for this also
if you're interested in it but but
essentially these endothelial cells in
this case the cuvette human umbilical
vein endothelial cells or other large
vessel and athelia cells would work well
in this also are seeded onto a gel
Trek's coated plate and they'll
spontaneously form these tubular
structures over time and you can use
this as a it's a it is a sort of classic
model of angiogenesis as it's I think
both strengths and weaknesses but
clearly it's a an application with the
gel tracks another shown below this is
do this is using an embedded culture so
putting so if we look at the left two
images we're looking at human mammary
epithelial cells cultured in 2d or in a
3d gel Trek's gel and and so in this
case what we see are structures these
acinar tubular like this model is
designed to help mimic ductal like
structures that occur in the breast from
which these these cells are derived from
so this is an example of using you know
translating these cells from 2d to 3d
with this gel Trek's matrix to
recapitulate structures that that are
seen in vivo with these cell types that
actually you may notice these sort of
spheroid structures that are the slide
on the lower right indicates these are
these are fixed hm a cross-sectional
slides where you can see they're
actually sort of hollow balls or acinar
structures and and these cells adapt a
spheroid or Myo more of a fibril cell
type to depending on the cell ratio so
you can kind of see that in the middle
lower slide I would mention too that
another key application for this this
material gel tract is in the use of
organoid culture this is an area that's
become you know has been seen rapid
growth over the the past couple years
that has really gone hand in hand in
glove with the you know the stem cell
world stem cell differentiation in in 3d
and these matrices like gel tracks are
really a typical and critical component
to forming these large organization
structures so just a little bit of a
different application but but but a key
one for for this matrix ok so again
teamed up I guess a stem cells a little
bit you know at that there are so both
Rhonda and I I guess you know we didn't
without reading her BIOS we spend a lot
of time in both the stem cell world IPSC
culture and differentiation as well as
of the primary cells and you know as
such I think we have you know a fairly
good perspective on or we've gained a
perspective on the value of these cells
in various applications and so I thought
it may be useful to put you know a table
up to two to sort of capture some of you
know at least my thoughts on the
differences in where you may find value
in one system versus the other and I
think they're clearly strengths and
weaknesses with both systems that is
taking you know normal human primary
cells or there are sort of stem cell
derived counterparts and so I listened a
few of the key ones here and so I mean I
mean I think right right off of the the
baton that this may be familiar for many
of you folks on the call but so during
and particularly with with you know IPS
see so rika induced pluripotent stem
cells there's an epigenetic reset during
the process and
so and the cells that come out of the
reprogramming and subsequent
differentiation from following
reprogramming tend to be fetal like an
early fetal like and so this can be a
challenge if you want to study you know
a number of you know a phenomenon that
happens in adults you know for example
so you know if a whereas we can you know
one can isolate primary cells from
individuals of different ages and look
at age-related you know characteristics
or features and indeed we we offer a
number of cell types from a neonatal
skin and an adult skin from from various
ages you know looking at those types of
you know age-related studies and stem
cells is difficult to impossible to do
right now similarly if you're looking at
complex disease phenomenon and
inflammatory diseases mechanisms of
disease that have a lot of epigenetic or
multi genetic components that can arise
over time or with you know sort of
environmental influences these can be
very very very challenging to model with
stem cells and again here's an area
where primary cells are really probably
ideally suited purity you know it really
varies I mean that's a typical ehind
primary cells because we've had a lot of
time to work through isolation
conditions with stem cells it's you know
it's variable I think it is getting
better a lot of the differentiation
protocols are getting more efficient but
you know so that's that's still a work
and you know uh that field is moving and
progressing so range of cell types you
know I think there are we are more
limited with primary cell types in
general this can be you know from
sourcing from from isolation there can
be just real challenges with getting
these certain cells and certain cell
types stem cells in principle unlimited
you should in principle be able to
derive but in practice you know it's not
on one
it's not unlimited um you can see with
the expansion capability is again
principle unlimited with stem cells
primary cells have a will synapse they
have a lifespan and that's you know part
of what makes them normal but but can
also be a challenge
okay so moving on again just to speak a
little bit to you know the workable
window was done with the with with a
primary cells and just in terms of you
know how many cells what can I expect in
terms of growth how many experiments can
I do with us you know what's you know
what's the relative you know how much
how much can I do with a single vial of
primary cells and so what we put this
table together to try and address that
somewhat and give you a gives you a
sense of a scale and so this table lists
on the left six different primary cell
types that we offer I put the first
column over is the AB so this is our
typical production scale average lot
size and then the next is sort of our
minimum population doublings so what's
the minimum life span and this is
something that we queue see our cell
products for so once when you get a vial
of current preserve cells from us
there's a certain viability there's a
there's a certain cell number and
there's us there's a you know guaranteed
expansion get minimum expansion
capability and we we typically will
measure this in population doubling it's
not passages they they certainly
correlate to each other but but
population doubling this is a more
accurate way to measure cell lifespan so
so here we're just looking at the
various cell types and if you you know
where to get a vial of these expand them
through there you know guaranteed
lifespan how many cells would you end up
per vial you can see these are you know
these are at minimum in the billions of
cells so it's really or more
and if you translate that to you know a
certain number of plates this is we used
a 384-well plate a format here but but
you can see you can you can really
you're thoughtful in how you plan and
expand and use these cells there's
really quite a bit of you know usable
material even even in a single vial okay
so I'm going to move into some of the
application data a good chunk of it is
going to be leveraging our back man
technology which is highlighted on this
slide so so back mam is really it's it's
a it's co-opting a bacala viral you know
baculovirus that recombinant baculovirus
to efficiently deliver genes to a
million cells we are on our second
generation of the back man technology
now and the back of virus you see the
cartoon image on the left has been
engineered to have improved tropism and
delivery to cells by by tinkering with
the coat proteins on the surface of the
virus and the expression cassette has
been optimized for high level sustained
expression in mammalian cells it's it's
really easy to use I'll go through the
workflow it's biosafety level one it's a
safe it's we see effectively no toxicity
within all practical ranges it has a
high cargo capacity so we can get you
know close to 38 KB or so I think it's
the largest content we've delivered you
can transduce cells with this and freeze
them make sort of you know large banks
of cells that you can pull out Muse I
should mention that this is also
transient what we found in general is
that the relative expression levels of
your trans gene of interest are similar
to that for transient transfection so
again it's a transient transient system
so workflow it's you know really very
very simple to
is simply just have yourselves add
sprinkles and virus on them or add the
virus we have specific guidance on
volumes or particles per cell or
relative you know sort of titers or mo
eyes to use but it's um it's still it's
very simple to even do this from from
volumetrically typically incubate
overnight and you can start to image or
quantify or do use the cells following
following day again to give you a sense
of kind of timing and dosing this is
looking at delivery of a bacala virus
encoding a GFP and untargeted green
fluorescent protein to human epidermal
keratinocytes at different doses or so
this would be different volumes of the
viral solution here or particles per
cell but it's very simply done
volumetrically and then looking at the
relative expression at one of these PPD
fixed volume in this case we're looking
at I think this was four hundred
particles per cell or so and looking at
expression of GFP over time so if you
look at the right set of images the the
column with the great so we're looking
at GFP expression starting at six hours
at the top and going down to 24 hours
the same field face contrast images are
shown below and then we're looking at if
you sort of you know go back to the
graph we're looking at you know at this
mo eye by 24 hours we're seeing
effectively you know 80 80 plus percent
transfected transduction efficiency so
so really efficient really easy to use
we found this to be a very nice reagent
for for content delivery across a wide
variety of cell types so I'm going to
touch on those right now so here we're
looking at back man again we're looking
at this is a different cargo and I'll
talk about some of that
in next couple slides Oh for some reason
I do not see the mouse cardiomyocytes up
here I don't know if that's showing up
on your screen or not but but
essentially I'd say we've really looked
across the board at a number of human
and rodent primary cell types and we get
very efficient it's a very very easy
easy delivery our similar workflow
highly efficient delivery across a range
of cell types so the next slide is going
to talk about the different types of
content so so this is a delivery vector
so we've built out a range of different
types of targets or assays sensors that
one can use here and also the you have
the ability to customize what we provide
custom services for for building out
viruses you can also we have DIY kits
now for four days viruses too so you
know there's really a range of options
for generating either getting
off-the-shelf reagents having us make
them or making them yourself the first
of so that the slide is going to look at
so I'm going to talk about just give you
examples of all of these areas of
content and and I think it's to
highlight the types of experiments one
can do within primary cells using these
reagents so the first is our cell light
a portfolio of products and these are
very simply RFP for their RFP or GFP
fusion proteins that have targeting
sequences fused to them that will
deliver and retain the fluorescent
protein in the indicated compartment so
it's a very simple and effective way to
image organelles or cellular structures
at you know in a dynamic way so this is
this can be all you can fix the cells
and do other stuff but you can also do
live cell imaging if you're interested
in trafficking or dynamics that may with
whatever treatment or biological context
you're looking at it if there are
dynamic changes
in any of these structures this is a
very nice way to track that track
quantify and image over time I won't
again this is just a slide showing
different flavors of those targeted GFP
or RFP constructs they work really well
they're very easy to use we have a
really nice there's some online tools on
how to pick and what do you want to look
at what other floors do you want you you
know if you wanted to do multiplex
imaging what's the right sort of set of
reagents to look at another one of the
back lamb encoded sets types of ranges
that we've that we've developed and
offered are those that are more specific
to interrogating the activity of
distinct signaling pathway signal
transduction pathways within within the
cell so the first one I'm just going to
kind of tee up this is another one of
our cell products this is a
cryopreserved
human skeletal myoblast the cartoon
shows and above that you can plate these
cells and within 48 hours they rapidly
differentiate and form multinucleated
myofibers so you know giving a very
rapid and robust human skeletal muscle
differentiation system what we're
showing here is that we can deliver the
the baculovirus we can apply the back
mammary agent to these cells and very
efficiently deliver the gfp to the
myofibers so that's indicated in the
sort of the 15 so the the upper-right
ICC image so this is GFP expression in
the myofibers the images below show same
field we're looking at in a nuclei in
blue or troponin so we're looking at a
marker of these mature skeletal
myofibers in red so it's a very very
efficient delivery so
what we so what the bat these things
back man pathway sensors enable you to
do is to look at distinct signaling
pathways and the appropriate biological
context and so in this case we're
showing so in muscle cells skeletal
muscle in particular the igf-1
insulin-like growth factor 1 and
tgf-beta pathways are really critical
for differentiation for muscle
maintenance for maintaining a healthy
muscle during disease conditions muscle
wasting - CAC CL so they're important
pathways in muscle and so what we're
showing here these are on the lower left
we've added get one of our pathway
sensors for the pi3 kinase Akt pathway
this is a LAN throw screen press 40 so
essentially this is a a phosphorylation
target that we're adding to the probe to
the cells encoded by the back man and
what we're reading over time is the
phosphorylation at 3 and n - 46 in this
price 44 I'm Alicia and so this is our
sort of our assay is going from very
little IGF to more this evolve these are
physiologically relevant levels of igf-1
you know sort of nanogram sub nanogram
per ml levels similarly when we look at
the tgf-beta either tgf-beta 1 or
related family member myostatin using a
phospho SMAT 3 LAN 'this green assay we
have again very nice sensitivity at
physiological levels for for both of
these growth factors so again we can
study the you know in this case the
pathways of interest with good
sensitivity in the right type in a
relevant biological background um
similarly I'm going to switch to a
different back man sensor and this is
one that we can do we can use for
intracellular calcium
sensing so this is the Corrin
encoded back ma'am it's delivered to
cells very very much like the same
workflow as I've shown before the the a
Corrin
in this case we have to load up with
collector zine that's the ctz little
pink molecule in the cartoon about
halfway through once the cells are
primed with this you can provide an
agonist
and and look for calcium signaling
following at agonists or antagonists you
know we're typically extracellular
receptor binding events or activation
events this is very sensitive it's sort
of a flash-based fluorescence it has a
very high signal-to-noise ratio I mean
there there are other there are robots
chemical sensors one can use also but
this the system does work very well for
for for high sensitivity and very low
signal noise this is just showing some
data with that system in this case we're
looking at delivering the back mamuh
quorum to two different primary cell
types on the Left is's are the human a
or Dec smooth muscle cells on the right
it's the human umbilical vein and
athelia cells and then we're looking at
dote these are dose responses or a
release of calcium and activation and
and the florets are luminescence of the
accoring following histamine stimulation
and so in this case were just were
utilizing the endogenous receptors on
the cell and putting basically a
positive control ligand and stimulating
the cells and you can if you look at the
you know the the y-axis it says a very
very broad or tall assay window
similarly we set up we're curious about
you know how would one compare a similar
type of screen these are these are wrote
so we're looking at chemical library
screens on either a workhorse Selma's
workhorse cell line so this is the top
panel that's this is the two night this
is a 293 s all that's been transduced
with the back panel corn or we're
looking at a primary cell the human
aortic smooth muscle cells that were
that had the according delivered and
then we're looking at so the top panel
sorry the top graphs are the 293 s the
upper left is a live one library plate
of agonist the other upper right is the
separate antagonist plate these are
commercially available libraries that we
were using below it's the same layout
but we're using the human a word exclude
muscle cells one thing we you know what
we realize right away is we had we had
good assay windows for both we have we
have pretty similar Z Prime's we also
had clear hits that are positive and
negative controls both were as expected
on this although what was interesting
here is that we actually if we look at
the different compounds the discrete
hits were different in the workhorse
line versus the primary cell line and so
again the context in which you are
asking your biological questions matters
and so this just gives flexibility to do
again comp compound screening and in
primary cells
okay so um
and it just quickly move on through a
couple a couple other slides and this is
really just addressing some of the other
we within Thermo Fisher Scientific have
a broad array of cell health reagents
these can be used in a wide array of
biological contexts
they're fairly simple endpoint
measurements
you know I've listed you know again here
the the modes of altered help so we can
measure city simply these are these are
almost all image based tools for
measuring apoptosis otology necrosis
cell proliferation we can drill down and
look at mitochondrial health
mitochondrial membrane potential you
know our OS species is a whole range of
them what we found broadly is they
translate very nicely into the primary
cell applications I'll just touch on two
of those so one this is using our
clickety two USA this is a surrogate for
the Arts actually a replacement for the
brdu measurement for cell proliferation
just it's very easy to use we found it's
highly compatible with the primary cell
as we've looked at as just a much easier
and simpler workflow than brdu more
sensitive
similarly here is this is a this is a
back man encoded reagent that it's our
future fuji cell cycle sensor and and
really what this this encodes two
different a red fluorescent protein and
green fluorescent protein that are fused
to either the protein domains that are
sensitive to cell cycle dependent
ubiquitination and turnover so
essentially you deliver both of them the
red protein is stable because of the CTD
fusion domain is stable during g1 but
rapidly becomes ubiquitinated and turned
over in s g2 and M so it really is its
expression
it's approach not expression the
stability of the protein is dependent on
the self state of the cell cycle
similarly the Gemini egfp fusion the
Gemini protein is rapidly ubiquity and
debt degraded during g1 so it's it's
that you don't essentially don't have
green GFP expression during the g1 phase
of the cell cycle but it's maintained
throughout that s g2 and M so again if
you need to do live cell imaging of if
you're looking at you know synchrony or
if you have events that you may may take
our cell cycle dependent it's a very
sort of easy and simple way to visualize
the state of the cells okay so with that
I don't buy to give you a sense of our
overview and some of the interesting
tools and reagents for primary cells I'm
going to hand it over to Rhonda to take
a focus dive into the organic using the
developing organic tipic skin models
thanks David and so that the workflow
for today's talk basically I'm going to
be talking to you about how we can
implement the cells and different
through my Fisher media rages together
to generate 3d epidermal skin models and
I'll be showing you how some of our
plastics technologies with a Tisch nut
tissue culture plates and their carrier
plates really facilitate this
stratification effort with minimum
hands-on time and briefly I'll touch on
how you could develop more sophisticated
models vehicle culture
first question is why would you want to
have through these skinned models and
obviously when we go to think about
different things and development of
consumer products or even for
understanding basic biology there are a
number of facets so one of them being
predictive toxicology so it's well known
that 3d epidermal Skin models and full
thickness skin models can also be
important for assessing the irritancy
and corrosive 'ti of various compounds
it can also be used to get a better
understanding a transdermal drug
delivery and furthermore it can be
really important in product development
so in particularly in the cosmeceutical
where people are looking at different
skin creams and lightening and darkening
reagents and obviously another you know
other areas of facilitating wound
healing
so today I'm going to take you through a
do-it-yourself protocol that we
generated using the thermo Fisher
reagents and describe that a bit to you
so first you'll start either with a
proliferating culture or you can use a
cry reserve bank of two to three prime
human epidermal keratinocytes and in
this instance you can use either
neonatal or adult keratinocyte and then
you would see those in two polycarbonate
membrane inserts and AD medium to the
upper and lower chambers then this
submerged culture growth continues for a
total of two days and then by changing
the media condition on such that you
raise the calcium chloride concentration
and also you raise it to the air liquid
interface such that is no longer fed
within the insert but rather just from
the bottom up and this is known as
raising to the air liquid interface and
this continues for eight to ten plus
days and and at the point you get very
nice stratification of your 3d models
and we have carried this out all the way
up to 23 days and see very nice
maintenance of these structures up to
that point
so overall the protocol takes two to
three weeks and it's a very versatile
protocol some of the things that I
called out all highlight here and the
protocol is available online as well at
the URL link shown there so as I
mentioned it is very flexible and that
you can use either a neo neo or result
you can also start from a flipper date
proliferating culture or cryo freezer
Bank and here you can see we started
from like this particular example is
from the 3-prime hex so you have quite a
bit of expandability so that you can get
a large number of models and I'll show
you later how you can couple this with
the nut inserts and carrier plates to
reduce your hands on time and as I
mentioned it's important to ensure that
you're varying your media condition
between the submerge culture and raising
to the air
good interface as the increase of
calcium chloride is important in the
stratification process so when it takes
you through a few of the properties of
these do-it-yourself 3d epidermal skin
models first we're going to look at the
histology so the image on the Left we're
highlighting a full thickness skin
explant and what you can see is you'll
see the up in dirt dermis there on the
top and the dermis is underneath and
it's comprised of a fibroblast rather
than criticizing a large collagen
composition
so as we're only focusing on the
epidermis for this do-it-yourself kit
you can see here's a representative 3d
skin model from that and I'll just fully
point through the where so here we have
our polycarbonate membrane that it is
cultured on and there are a wide variety
of different membranes that that cells
can be cultured on and different cell
types like different different membranes
and again in this instance polycarbonate
is the toys you can see the progenitor
later layer of stratum basale followed
by stratum spinosum and stratum
granulosum
and then finally you get your extra
outside surface of the skin and then as
the stratum corneum and that will grow
as the dust cells become more aged
so overall we see that we have a very
appropriately stratified epidermis
generated using this protocol
furthermore if we look at immunise and
chemistry looking at markers of
differentiation and these skin models we
see very nice correlation with what we
see with a skin explant so here looking
at epidermis and dermis reminder that in
the explains we have both compartments
there for keratin 10 this is this is
meant to highlight the status of
progenitor layer the basal layer and you
can see in our of a dermal model it is
right along the surface of the
polycarbonate insert and mimics very
nicely what you see with the skin
explained with keratin 14 this is the
early marker of differentiation so it's
not MD it isn't in the basal layer of
stuff of cells in the stratum basale
but rather in the layers above and you
can see it's nice expression in
correlation with what we see in the skin
explant if bullet Crenn is an
intermediate marker and so you can see
it see it spread a little throughout and
it correlates very nicely with what we
see with this skin explant whereas la
gran is a late marker of differentiation
you see that in that outer surface of
the of the cells
so overall our 3d epidermal skin models
also have very next marker expression so
as I mentioned earlier predictive
toxicity is an a key area for use of
these 3d scan model equivalents so a
couple of different things that are
important there is the barrier
properties and these can be assessed
either using an eighty fifty measurement
which I'll go through with you now as
well as trans epithelial electrical
resistance or tur measurements and I all
briefly mention those so in the EP 50
measurement what you'll do is you'll
take your skin model and dose it
topically and incubate it for a range of
incubation times and I'll step through
some of that data then you copiously
wash the model and then you'll transfer
it to a dish containing a viability
reagent and there's a number of them
available the MTT is a validated
viability reagent for this given purpose
you can also we've also tested things
like xct i'll mark blue press the blue
as well but in this instance using MTT
as you incubate it for three hours in
that solution basically the live cells
will turn cold due to the generation of
the formants in crystals
whereas the dead tissues will remain
okay and finally you'll extract that
color from them and measure the
absorbance at 540 nanometers and here's
just representative data showing what
you what you expect so in this instance
you will have water as a negative
control and that should be added at the
longest treatment time in your in your
testing scheme so here since we went out
to nine hours our negative control is
tested at nine hours we also would have
a positive control here we use five
percent SDS and you can see that it it
has a large impact on the viability of
the cells and then subsequently if we
look at one percent right next 100 you
can see that there is a time response
cue to this where
at seven and a half hours it's at
roughly 50% viable
so these 3d epidural models do
demonstrate good barrier properties with
eg 50 of around seven hours and
furthermore if you were to look at the
trans epithelial electrical resistance
depending upon the model that you've
derived it could be anywhere between
four and seven thousand ohms per
centimeter squared
so now I want to talk to you a little
bit about coupling of our fellow
ourselves and media with the non so
culture inserts and carrier plates and
this is a very nice development that
reduces the amount of hands-on time
basically you take these monthly
carbonate answers and you can put those
into carriers plates and they're
available in both 12 well and 24 well
formats and they lock into these terror
plates and one of the really nice things
is that is that it can lock in at
various position so you can have it a
high medium or a low position depending
on the amount of medium and the
frequency of seed that you want to
attain so this is a very nice very nice
complement and it does allow for less
frequent feed schedules another thing I
did want to mention is that the nunc
inserts are also available in three
different pore sizes and this allows you
to have flexibility in your research
because not only are the net Excel
culture inserts important for things
such as the epidermal skin
stratification but if you are interested
in cell division assays or other types
of things then those are available to
you so here we just want to show using
the non carrier system how it if words
flexibility in the feed schedule so
again there's the three different insert
positions as you raise the insert
position obviously you need to include
more medium in the lower compartment and
what this before is is that that you
don't have to change the medium as it
frequently is in the protocol the
original protocol that we worked off of
we were doing these strategies every
other days here you can skip up to four
days
so if we look at that overall
stratification of these models here's at
the low position you see nicer on basil
starting spine ISM stratum granulosum
stratum corneum and the same for the
immediate middle position as well as the
high position
oh so it does show the appropriate a
stratification for all three positions
so now I just want to lightly touch on
how you might achieve a more
sophisticated model by implementation of
it's a human epidermal melanocytes and
we do with offer these in a range of
pigmented types from moderate to dark
pigmented human epidermal melanocytes
and so in this particular instance we
have the control which is 100% human
epidermal occasion sites from an adult
or a pigmented in which was added 77 /
93 heke
and so you can already see the darkening
and the bottom but as you add l dopa
this will cause that to magnify the dark
name to magnify and if you look at the
overall stratification you can begin to
make out some of the melanocytes or
contributing to the darkening of the
layers
so this is one way in which you can
aquaculture method in which you can
increase the flexibility of the system
so as I mentioned that protocol is
available online and here is just a
snapshot of we provide the cells media
and supplements with the exception of
queue of the rate reagents they're all
available and we've also tested this
with a presence as an antibiotic in anti
my Kotik which again is optional but
it's nice to have that security blanket
for a long long differentiation truths
or stratification periods and then also
I highlighted they use of the
polycarbonate inserts and the carry
trade
so with that I think David take you
through a very David and I both took you
through a diverse range of primary salt
offerings that we provided thermo Fisher
and also discussed a bit about how we
can couple that with the different media
and matrices that we offer we can offer
off-the-shelf solutions but also custom
of even animal origin or defined culture
medium and reagents so definitely reach
out to us if you have questions on on
that front and then we also highlighted
specific examples where you can pair
together our media and cells together
with a plastic ware to further expand to
physiologically relevant endpoint so we
want to thank you for your attention in
today's presentation and open up the
floor to questions
Thank You dr. von Neumann and dr. David
commander for your great presentation as
dr. Neumann mentioned it is time for our
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
do have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now and click on that F ask
a question located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for ok let's
get started
are you able to obtain other cell types
I don't see my cell on your list
so
possibly and I think so this is an area
we have so first we have a specific form
that we can you know that can you can go
to your thermo Fisher sales rep for or
find it online what we found is it can
often be cost prohibitive to go I mean
it just to be just completely
transparent here it may depend on how
much you want is really because if we
don't currently make it we're going to
have to spend some time on the isolation
condition you know it is it can be a
little bit time-consuming and costly for
us to go after other cell types there
are very different cell types that
aren't listed so if it's something that
you really need and you know you need it
to run a program or you would anticipate
you know you know let's say more than
ten vials or you know a substantial
volume of self it would probably be
worth discussing if not it may it may
just be cost prohibitive for us to do
that I would say that there what we
often do is we'll go after different for
it yeah so uh maybe I'll just leave it
at that okay well doctor kind of driving
a piggyback on that question and I have
a more specific one asking do you
provide osteoblast osteoclast spells
no we don't we don't we don't currently
provide them I mean the yeah we have
yeah we have em SCS what so I'm sorry is
Rhonda was mentioning our sorry sitting
here um
no so formally we have we do offer the
progenitor cell type from which they are
derived so mesenchymal stem cells we
have in a couple of flavors so that's
probably as close as we could do so we
don't have the osteoblast or osteoclast
per se but the progenitors from which
they are derived okay thank you
next question two-part what message have
you found to be the most successful in
transfecting primary cells and do other
non viral methods work yeah that's a
really good question um so
I say as a general rule with us
electroporation is a very effective
method to deliver nucleic acid content
to primary cells so we offer the neon
system although I know that wasn't the
question specifically it you know it's a
little bit of a caveat and answer so we
have transfection Rhee I'm going to
assume we're going to we're talking
about delivering mid sized DNA plasmids
here but so we have a range of
transfection reagents that have that I'd
say work well - okay
in primary cells depending on the cell
type so that would be our life effect
amine 3000 or even the earlier
generation life effect coming to sounds
or and but what we do provide is on the
website and I don't know the URL off the
top of my head but you could look up
life effect amine and transfection guide
and there's a very extensive table
that's listed on there that would
provide you know the guidance for the
reagents and DNA ratio so some overall
transaction you know what you might
expect to see what we would recommend is
some general transduction guidance there
um prude to piggyback on what David said
the neon electroporation does work very
well and there's a very large table that
covers a very diverse range of cell
types that can be effectively delivered
in the neon the nice thing about it as
you despite whether you're delivering
protein nucleic acid you know it
delivers much everything so much more
flexibility there
but that required that's what that
requires the someone has the instrument
yeah instead of just a consumable that
the reate transfection reagent is
thank you here's another question how
about capillaries in 3d skin models
so we've not we've not worked on that
per se yeah as far as we've gone it's
just with the introduction of
melanocytes obviously as you get more
sophisticated models you could start
putting in dermal equivalent
I've not seen great success with
capillaries you know being in those
systems at this time
okay now what is the greatest challenge
in developing a three model of human
skin using this system
so one of the really great things about
the human epidermal keratinocytes and
one of the things that was highlighted
when David slides is the expandability
of them is really great and so it's not
so much that cell source this is the one
thing that I say is keeping an eye on
your inserts that you're not getting any
air bubbles trapped beneath them and so
that can sometimes be tricky because
obviously you want you want it the media
to be able to go all the way through the
bottom of the answer so I would say that
that's a tricky part also if you're
wanting to make more complicated models
such as full thickness and models all
you can embed fibroblasts into you rat
tail collagen that if you're looking at
wind chilling applications not all
fibroblasts are equivalent so there may
need to be additional screening factors
that are considered there
okay um how about the one that just came
in I'm focused on crisper based
knockouts have you done anything with
crisper and your primary cells
we haven't done as well I don't know
about the custom biology team no um we
have this a very interesting question
though we're looking at we have we have
a number of two tools yeah so CRISPR
crisp CRISPR based screening tools that
are encoded by lentiviruses and and so
we think that that that would be we
would expect to have good good delivery
with those those vectors into these
cells as Rhonda mentioned also the nyan
electroporator we know we can
effectively deliver well we have we have
more data with stem cells but we know we
can effectively deliver a variety of you
know protein RNA you know the guide
protein guide complexes or plasmid based
plasmid base crisper and a husband based
cast 9 and CRISPR guides effectively
also by electroporation so yeah I think
it would we don't have the data here but
yeah it should be lend itself to yeah
either other way yeah and there a lot of
times we working with broken stem cells
you use like a heck 293 is the positive
control to say that your tools are
working and Isis I realize it's not a
primary cell but it should be very
similar and there's a new new offering a
true cat to cut cast 9 nucleus which is
really great because it has a more
efficient nuclear localization trading
signal in it there's also synthetic
guide RNAs that you can order their
costume and deliver away so again the
neon I think is the best option there
Thank You dr. Newman and thank you dr.
cannon sure we're on the side of time
but would either of you like to leave
our audience with any final comment
I mean I just say you know again for
those of you who are still with us thank
you
well you know thanks for thanks for
attending I hope it was useful we did
have contact information for Rhonda and
myself or our business partners and
we're happy to have any you know you
know we're here doing this all the time
we you know happy to - you know I handle
any follow-up questions or or discuss
anything that comes out of this thank
you thank you again and thank you for
your important research before we go I
also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions any question that
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration also like to
thank labret our camp Mavericks and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through September 2018 Labyrinth will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's wide event thanks
again for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon bye bye
you
and we're clear